I want to play this clip for you I saw
this from Isabelle Brown on Instagram so
we're doing a a a picture and a picture
video or uh we're reacting to a reaction
but I don't know the original video but
I'm gonna play this for you
they don't know how to address an
envelope
they don't know how to read cursive
they're talking about gen Z
I don't know how to read a paper map
they can't get anywhere unless there's a
GPS map on their phone
all I'm saying is that gen Z takes over
the world it's kind of
it's gonna be we're just gonna write our
battle plans in cursive on a piece of
paper
that actually is a true story we talked
about it before look at her face swear
up well so there's that story where they
did the war game and the younger guys
lost to the older guys and it's because
like the older guys wrote and wrote
their plans on a note and put in a guy's
pocket and wrote it by motorcycle and
they were trying to like intercept
messages people talk about it they tell
us the specifics but Isabelle then goes
on a mention that uh
you were supposed to teach us yeah and
that's the most brutal thing about it
that woman she's telling a joke it's
fine it's a joke but the crazy thing is
that she would joke about her own
failures a generational failure and they
all laugh and I'm like
I bet you're joking
but every joke has its truth and you
don't genuinely think you will take the
world back from gen Z you do believe
you're handing it off but if you really
believe that gen Z is incompetent and
capable and you're laughing about it
this is us being flushed down the drain
when did we go serious question for you
guys when did we go from a nation where
we were like we need to prepare our
children for the future to you're on
your own I can't believe they can't do
these things
when we trusted public schools to teach
our kids and didn't pay enough attention
to see the changes happening I think
that's completely it let's go all the
way back to schools either like I
witnessed this happen at a summer camp
that I was working at like a
skateboarding camp where a few people
who are really into this started like
asking kids their pronouns and doing
these types of rituals like when we
would do our and it's all active games
and stuff yeah it's it's like very very
leftist activists and I was sitting
there thinking like why are we talking
to 12 year olds like this we're supposed
to be skateboarding and playing fun like
get to know you games like their parents
didn't agree to this and I don't want to
be a part of this and I ended up leaving
but it's hard to stay in a position like
that when the people in control are
pushing that I think I think this
started with public schooling I think
about why it is that so many why does
gen Z not want to work
there was a story I saw the other day
and it said gen Z doesn't want to work
poll shows but and I'm like okay what
does work mean seriously what is what
does work refer to I wake up every day I
work like 16 hours every single thing I
do is work and it's fun I'm having fun
everything I'm doing is in the is in the
pursuit of some kind of work we go
skateboarding it's like yeah we're
filming videos we're launching a show
we're going to be setting up a park
we're going to be making things for
people to enjoy and to consume and to be
inspired by
these younger people
and it's not just younger people but
it's in case it's it's increasing with
the generations don't want to do
anything
they are nihilistic not all of them I'm
not saying everybody but there's a lot
of more nihilistic they want to lay
around they don't even want to read
books they don't want to watch TV they
want to watch movies they might just put
on the office on Netflix and just sit
there
what happened where people I'll tell you
what I think
here's how it used to be
dad wakes up and uh he goes all right
son off to work come on and he'd bring
his kid with him to his you know wood
shop or whatever and this is hundreds of
years ago and he would show his son what
he did and his son would be there and
he'd be like go grab the tools from the
shed and then the kid will watch him do
it as the kid got older the kid would
get more responsibility from his dad and
then when the dad was old and was like I
can't do this job anymore the kid would
be like don't worry Dad I'll keep the
the shot running and then you get this
like seven generation you know
woodworking thing and it becomes a big
company inherited all the kids learning
the whole way and then at some point we
said I got an idea let's take the kids
away from their parents so they don't
learn put them in an institutionalized
learning facility for general education
separating them from their parents
and then they don't work
when they're in school they learn
General stuff they play
they take tests well if you take a kid
and their development is tests guess
what they're going to be good at when
they're older reading books and taking
tests yeah and then they turn into
career students too because it's like
you're almost expected to go to college
out of high school without even knowing
what you're going to college for and
then once you're in college and you're
halfway through you're like I don't know
what I'm gonna do still and then it's
like okay I'm gonna get another degree
and another degree and they become
career students and they're actually
learning nothing of value and just
obtaining a ton of debt yeah exactly but
they'll never be able to crawl out of
I'll tell you what I did when I was a
little kid
since I was alive my family had
computers I guess I had like my uncle
was into it my mom got a computer we had
like two a floppy disks we had
CompuServe on dos shell or dos and dos
shell eventually we had dos games so I'm
always using computers we had the
internet my whole life I'm on AOL I'm on
CompuServe and AOL I'm a little kid
parental restrictions and stuff but I'm
I'm you know browsing the internet
eventually I'm downloading programs I
start reading news articles I used to go
to farc.com all the time do you guys
remember farting yeah yeah that was good
fun
man I was probably like 13 when I'm
reading these news stories all of a
sudden there I am skating with my
friends but having read the news all day
and then we would be talking about the
stuff and I'd be like oh yeah I read
this story and I was well here I am as
an adult quite literally doing very much
the exact same thing I've always done
and I look at what's happening now at
the younger generation and what what
they're being taught the moment we
separated kids from their parents that
was when the roots were cut and you you
created this domino effect of parents
who don't teach their kids who have kids
who don't teach their kids and then
after a few Generations
it all just crumbles and now you've got
comedians laughing being like gen Z's so
incompetent I'm like you're the ones who
are supposed to have passed on the
knowledge and capabilities to gen Z they
didn't do it they've all just said it's
someone else's responsibility and what
we're seeing now is the worst of it
where these teachers are trying to
indoctrinate kids with this weird
groomer stuff
yeah for sure and then the thing too
about like what you mentioned about not
enough states fighting a bat fighting
back against you know the education
system doing that uh you saw the
backlash in Florida there was a national
campaign almost a smear that don't say
gay bill when in actuality it was you
know the parental rights and education
exactly and they kept saying the
so-called don't say gay Bill to discur
responsibility but you had people like
saying oh Ron DeSantis called it this
it's like well no it wasn't actually his
legislation and then also the reality of
it it's like you can't like teach
toddlers like sexual education and you
know without their parents consent it's
like that was the actual you know Bill
and there was a national conversation
against it and that was just like at a
state level so you know imagine if
another state that isn't as red as
Florida did that you know the national
Spotlight kind of makes States not want
to take it on because it is an uphill
battle when you know the actual National
media get involved in the conversation
when I think think about this stuff it
makes me very very optimistic because I
kind of feel like we're actually coming
out of the crisis period the stuff that
we're seeing and people waking up and
people saying homeschool your kids
homeschooling your kids is literally
what you were supposed to be doing what
humans have always done the kids were
learning from their parents and then we
got to a point where we had schools I
know that we've had school houses for a
very very long time hundreds of years
but we got to the point where everything
became heavily institutionalized and
then parents started not caring about
what their kids were learning the
culture started to fragment and then you
had kids learning weird things and now
we're at the worst point of it where you
got these books like genderqueer and
this book is gay which is like Kink
education for children which should not
be in these schools but now people are
starting to reverse course and it's
almost like the pendulum swung back and
it's starting to go back the other
direction like people are starting to
say yeah we shouldn't have this for our
kids and if we start implementing pod
learning across the board then the
future looks pretty bright
it's also been the economy because you
had in the 1950s you had one parent that
could stay at the house with the
children well and you know it was one
salary you could pay for a nice house
and a nice safe neighborhood now you
have many single-parent households and
if they're two parent households usually
both parents are working so these
children have
you know they don't have that parent
around all the time they're they're sent
to public school because it's daycare
you know yeah and so that's that's what
it's become the date the fact that the
fact that public school has become
daycare as opposed to an actual place
for kids to go and learn stuff is is
probably the biggest problem the United
States is facing the fact that parents
aren't involved in their kids lives I
think that that's not just about the
whole woke thing but like there's a lot
of crime problems that come from that
you know kids that don't have families
that whether they be you know whatever
you consider a family like I don't have
a big strong has to be a dad has to be a
mom I I think that it's okay if you have
two moms or two dads I personally I
think it's fine but you have to have a
masculine and a feminine kind of parent
or those roles have to be filled somehow
and kids aren't getting that you
certainly don't get it from a single mom
and I understand there's a lot of single
moms out there busting their hump but
it's not easy the the media has lied to
single mothers tell them that they can
be a single mother and a CEO of Fortune
500 company you know and that's you just
can't you there's no way you're gonna
have time for both your kids deserve way
more time than what you could give if
you're working full-time so I think the
problem the biggest problems that we
have are the fact that there aren't
people you know or that parents aren't
raising their kids probably they're
sending them off to school and not
taking them to work with them and and to
teach them to do stuff so hmm
that's my my opinion about the biggest
problems is just schools yeah but I
think we're taking it back I think the
covid thing triggered something
accidentally that's freaking out the
left and that parents got to actually
hear what their kids were being told for
the first time basically ever
when I hear about these stories out of
West Virginia
parents say like my kid came home and
started saying weird stuff you know
talking about pan pan sexual and gender
stuff and then they're like what's
what's going on they're finally now
realizing it but it's too late these P
these teachers that got hired the people
got brought to the school boards they
infiltrated but people are waking up to
it and it's causing a shift finally
people are going to be are saying and
where it used to be well look you know
go to school and you know ignore that
stuff now the parents are like whoa this
is just too much thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time